Today we're talking about storytelling.
If you want to sell more with
copywriting, you have to learn to tell
better stories. And here's the thing
that may shock you. Every great story
uses the exact same system from Jesus in
the Bible to Katniss and Hunger Games.
And this one super simple system is
going to 10x your storytelling almost
instantly. And after watching this, I
guarantee that you will think
differently about the way you write copy
and sell with stories. By the way, I'm
Alan Drau. I've sold over $2 million
with my copy and over 10,000 copywriters
study my stories. This is what I do all
day long. All right, let's dive into the
system. Every great story is broken out
into three sections. Here's what happens
in each section. Section one, there is a
good character. Section two, something
bad happens to that good character.
Section three, the good character beats
the bad thing. This is traditionally
called the hero's journey. But before I
show you how it's used in movies, books,
and sales letters, I want to visualize
it for you and show you how the system
works. All right, here's section one.
Your good character is in a tree. Life
is good. He's chilling, reading books,
having a snack. All things are going
well. But then one day, you set the tree
on fire. Something bad happens to your
character. His dad dies. He loses his
job. He gets in a car wreck. His world
is shaken up. But then something or
someone comes along and helps your good
character get out of the burning tree.
Life is good again. He beats the bad
thing. Your readers are happy. This
three scene storytelling system is used
by some of the greatest stories ever
told. Let me give you some examples.
Number one, Jesus in the Bible. Jesus is
a good guy. Shepherd, carpenter, living
life. All is well. Then he gets murdered
on the cross. But then Jesus taps into
his super mighty god powers and he
resurrects from the dead, beating the
big bad thing. Or what about this one?
Lion King. Simba, good guy on the way to
becoming king of Pride Rock. But then
crazy uncle murders his dad who is the
king. But then Rafiki helps Simba beat
the crazy uncle and become the king of
Pride Rock. All right, couple more. Two
more. Hunger Games. [snorts]
Katniss is living in section 11 with her
sister and her mom. Life's okay. Then
she gets drafted into the Hunger Games
by a corrupt government where she has to
fight to the death for their
entertainment. But with the help of
Hamage, her mentor, she wins the Hunger
Games and overthrows the corrupt
government. Life is good. Is this
catching on? All right. How about a How
about a copyrightiting example? The
infamous one-legged golfer sales letter
by John Carlton. Here's the story. Young
guy named Milt Wallace is a really good
golfer. Then one day he loses his left
leg in a freak accident. But then he
finds a coach who teaches him this
famous triple coil golf swing that not
only teaches him how to play golf with
one leg, but hit the ball further and
better than he ever did with two legs. I
could go on because there are millions
of stories that use this exact system
because it works. But here's the magic
sauce on how to use it specifically for
increasing your sales with
copyrightiting. The secret to sales is
your good character is in a tree. You
set the tree on fire. The way that they
get out of the burning tree is by buying
your product. You see what happens with
sales copy when you tell a good story is
that your reader sees themsself as the
main character. And what happens when
you tell a great story is your reader
not only sees themsself as the main
character, but sees themsself as the
main character in a burning tree. Your
job as the copywriter is to prop a nice
ladder up against that burning tree.
Lift out your hand and say, "Would you
like some help getting out of this
burning tree?" And the way they get out
of the tree is by buying your product.
Let me show you. Let's go back to the
John Carlton sales letter. All right.
Your reader plays golf. They suck at
golf. This is their burning tree. They
wish they could hit the ball further and
shoot lower scores so that way they can
show off to their friends. And while
this reader is in a burning tree, they
get a letter from you. And it talks
about a guy who was in the same exact
burning tree, except he was able to
solve his problem with this famous
triple coil golf swing, i.e. your
product. Then you make an offer to the
reader. If you too would like to solve
this problem, then you can buy X for Y
amount of dollars. And in the reader's
mind, they're instantly saying,
"No-brainer. You can do this in emails,
in sales letters, in VSSLs, in meta ads,
in YouTube scripts. It works anywhere
and everywhere." And if you do this, I
guarantee at the bare minimum, you will
at least double or triple your sales
conversion rates. And if you found this
video helpful and you want me to make
more content to help you sell more with
copywriting, then all I ask is that you
hit like on the video and subscribe to
the channel. It tells YouTube to support
creators just like me. And if you want
to read some of the best dang stories in
the copywriting space, I highly
recommend clicking the link in the
description below to check out my daily
email list. I send one email every
single morning with a great story that I
guarantee you cannot stop reading. In
fact, over 5,000 copywriters read my
emails every day. And when you sign up,
you also get my free guide, Copywriting
Catalyst, the minute you join my list.
It's 63 cash cow copywriting secrets
that will help you explode as a
copywriter. I appreciate the support.
Thanks so much for watching the video.
Feel free to go ahead and browse around
my other videos. Get lost in the rabbit
hole. And I will catch you on the next
one. Man, that John Carlton sales
letter. That thing is so heat. So fire.
I'll put that in the description, too.
If you guys have never read it, I'll put
it down in the link below so you can
click that, read that. Dude, that is a
killer sales letter. Shout out to Johnny
C. I don't know him personally. I I
probably should I could reach out to
him. I could be like, "Yo, what up? I
just like shouted you out on my YouTube
channel. Should we collab? Should we do
something together? Should we write a
sales letter together? Me and Johnny C."
That would be heat. That would be fire.
Fire.